well
um
go ahead tom pelicero seems to disagree
that they remain unwilling to discuss qb
desean watson with other teams some of
whom have resorted to leaving voicemails
with trade offers per sources what if
their voicemail is full
what are their voicemails full uh watson
spoke briefly to coach david kelly
recently
yep uh but the two still haven't met in
person houston not budging
old mccabey um
dan graziano and adam schefter have been
tweeting as well first sources
he met with texas head coach david
culley last friday
uh in that meeting he reiterated that he
wants to be traded and told kelly has no
intention of playing for the texans
again
no change from watson's end he remains
dug in
so
we have a mexican standoff here that's
what we have
the game of texans hold'em
or texans hold him
uh continues
so
i mean hey
you just crack your knuckles i've said
enough
i did i've said enough
um maybe i'll maybe i'll weave some more
uh you know
guessing
uh in there in a minute uh what's your
thoughts
now that uh
not at the words that they've talked
mike you've been all over this you've
been all over this so good job that was
on tuesday and and you laid it out uh
pretty methodically the only thing i
disagree with you
on something you said on tuesday i don't
think it's going to happen but
everything else i think is spot on you
think the j.j watt and desean watson are
going to the same place i don't think so
i think j.j watt's going to go his own
way especially
if he can get that all that money on the
table he can get like 15 16 million a
year he's not going to go to the same
place deshaun watson goes to but i want
to focus on what especially i want to go
sorry just just to interject real quick
just interject real quick especially if
the texans insist on dragging this thing
out jj might not want to wait much
longer yeah but go ahead
or or or maybe
we go with where jj watson goes that
might be the tip
on where deshawn watts is going because
deshawn watson can say look
i'm going to this team
so go ahead
go ahead and we're watching where what
goes that's where watson's going but
anyway now you
now you're thinking how are you thinking
hey
hey
but you know what mike i think what
stands out to me is the houston texans
are just a bad franchise
and i'm going to say specifically
because i know a lot of people say that
but i'm going to spec i'm going to
specifically tell you
why they're a bad franchise you ever
argue with somebody
and then they get across to you they get
they they say something
that you want to agree with
you actually want to say something nice
to them but they just i don't want to
hear it i don't want to hear it oh no
not stop talking you can't even reason
with them you got to tell them look
i got something good for you why are you
fighting me on this
i'm going to tell you something
that you want to hear
and the texans right now
you are doing a bad job i don't know who
it is
i don't know if it's cal mcnair i don't
know if it's jack eastwood i hope it's
nick casario i don't know if it's cully
i don't know if it's all of them i don't
know if it's two of them whoever you are
you're doing a bad job for the houston
texans if you refuse to listen to 31
other teams in the league and i know
it's not 31 other teams but let's take
15 teams
if 15 teams in the league
are calling you to talk about a trade
for deshaun watson and deshawn watson
has told you
he doesn't want to play for you you are
not serving the franchise
by ignoring those phone calls mike if
i've got an asset
if i've got an asset
and i'm in an industry in an industry
where half of the people or a third of
the people in that industry want the
asset that i have
but that asset's not going to work for
me got to work for somebody else
i'm being negligent
i'm being stubborn
inflexible if i'm not going to open that
up and say all right
it's not going to work forever i wish it
had worked out
yeah but it's time to move forward
amicably
with deshaun
i've used this phrase so many times
i've used this phrase so many times when
it comes to this franchise they're
cutting off their nose to spite their
face they're trying to prove a point we
gonna trade you when we're good and
ready
so here's the thing they're going to
trade him
but they may not trade him
and it doesn't look good
if you believe the reports again i'ma
stand by what i
think i know
okay
which is that
maybe they return the calls
but they've checked their voicemail i
don't think their voicemail's full
maybe they've left a lot of these texts
on on red but they got them
okay
because
again they continue to underestimate
how dug in desean is
you know and i know i'm biased but it's
like
that you know he is not
going to play there
he will end up sitting if he has to
that's going to happen if that's what it
comes down to he's not going to put on a
uniform those pictures that's the last
you're going to see desean watson in the
texas uniform that's it he's not playing
for them
and they keep acting like this is
somebody who's just needs some time to
cool off
that he's going to change his mind that
david culley
sweet talking him and whispering sweet
nothing's in his ear is going to make
him change his mind he told david culley
this ain't got nothing to do with you
i'm not playing here anymore so that's
that's that so the texans have a choice
they can do this the easy way or the
hard way and clearly they want to do
this the hard way so okay we're going to
do it the hard way they're going to end
up trading him but it's going to be
after they
punish him
because that's how they're wired
instead of doing the right thing doing
the best
because who the hell wants somebody yeah
who wants somebody there that doesn't
want to be there like i mean that's just
that's just how i operate like you don't
want me here i don't want to be here and
if i don't want to be here why would you
force why would you hold them hostage
what good does that do you you could
play that game with a cornerback you
could play that game with an offensive
tackle you could play that game with a
wide receiver you could you cannot play
that game with the face of your
franchise
well the face of your franchise michael
holly the face of your franchise cannot
wear a frown the face of your franchise
cannot wear a skowl
the face of your franchise cannot have
wandering eyes for miami or san
francisco
the face of your franchise has got to be
in he's got to be at the same vision as
you do you're not doing yourself any
favors by not trading before the draft
but they're going to mess around and
they're going to pull up they want to be
the bengals they're going to pull a
carson palmer they're going to test him
and they're going to end up trading him
who knows when with all these picks that
the dolphins have waiting for them ain't
available so anyway
yeah you got i mean i think you got to
read the room you got to read the not
not the room well yeah you have to read
the room the room is telling you desean
wants someone to go wants to go but you
also have to read the atmosphere and the
atmosphere right now
is that a guy like deshawn watson has a
talent now he has a talent to bring you
three first-round picks if not more and
other players i know peter king put out
that scenario the other day of hey this
is what it might take
but you've got this guy and you've got
some teams
at the top of the draft who can give you
exactly what you lack
and i'm thinking of the of of the texans
fan
i feel sorry for him feel sorry for a
texas fan for a couple of reasons
because they're stuck in the middle of
this fight
you know
there's a divorce and they're stuck
in the middle of the divorce no matter
whose side you take it's not a good side
you're taking the side of the texans but
the texans are not moving forward
they're stuck
something needs to happen but the texans
say we're going to stay here
and we're just going to grit our teeth
and
deshawn watson yes he agreed to a
contract extension with the franchise
but now he wants out and they won't let
him go and if you're a houston texans
fan you know what's going to happen
in the 2021 season i'm going to tell you
right now you were 4 and 12 last year
you might have a slightly better record
but you're going to be the same kind of
team if not worse j.j watt's gone
deshawn watson's not going to be there
your team didn't make any moves to
improve your draft position
which they could have so you might win
five games maybe
but you've really already i i'm gonna go
on record and say it i say it with
confidence
i said it i meant it i'm here to
represent it um the the 2021 nfl season
for the houston texans is a waste you
already punted yeah punt on first down
right now it's over
look you're like
hostage is no good
they're holding him hostage and really
themselves like because if if he's
do they just think he's gonna like just
you know what it is man it goes back to
and it's funny
you know there was just this huge
article
uh from espn my man seth rickersham and
don vanata
um about damaris smith which maybe we
get into before the week's over well
it's almost friday but the point is a
week's over you know
yeah
this big thing about uh you know inside
his cba negotiations over the years and
his
relationship and reputation between the
players and and the league but i only
bring that up to say it's like like nfl
teams and owners they always just assume
that players are just going to cave
like like like they like they're bought
and sold like oh well you know you you
have a contract
you have so you know you got you want
you want your money right
you know we we hold the cards we we got
you right where we want you you gonna
play for us and nobody we own you it's
like this dude he ain't wired like that
this is not a holdout this is not
somebody who i mean desean watson came
from nothing this money ain't going to
his head
like he's not sitting around saying oh
man you know what
i'm just going to like
see if they'll let me go
see here's the difference he russell
wilson this ain't russell wilson this
ain't well i want to play here but if a
trade were considered this ain't that
this ain't this ain't that this ain't
you know i'm i'm gonna just throw a
temper tantrum but at the end of the day
i'm just gonna show up hat in hand and
do my job that's not what's going down
here
and it's and the sooner they come to
grips with that and i believe they know
that i believe they continue to posture
at this point it's my strong belief with
all due respect everybody's reporting i
believe that they're they're they're
they're doing their internal due
diligence and they're having their
conversations they didn't hang up the
phone with sean watson and they
eventually start returning calls
[Music]
that's not what they did anything with
deshaun watson eventually returning
calls
they they're they're figuring out right
now okay
how we gonna spend this how are we gonna
play this how we gonna swallow our pride
and do what's best for the franchise
because michael as you me and everybody
else have pointed out they could make a
killing off of this deal they could make
a killing off of this
they will do it they can make the kills
all their picks back miami will give
them tour their picks back and more
for desean watson tomorrow
a deal is there tomorrow they could sit
up here do you think the jets just would
the jets do it will the jets make a move
i think the just traders would entertain
it i don't i don't think that the jets
will want to go too far i don't think
the jets are as gung-ho as miami and
also
sean is not as high on the jets
um
as some may have believed some being me
at one point i don't think the jets are
as high on his listen he's got the no
trade claws
you know i don't think the jets
what some others i think is what i think
it's miami
what what did quinn and williams become
a part of this trade
i think that was the peter king one that
was a peter king proposal yeah okay
that's asking that's asking for a bunch
but i know i i know we disagree on this
you feel like
anybody
you know no matter no matter what the
trade is no matter what you give up for
deshaun watson you win the trade and i
actually think uh
i understand that texans i understand
that i think that's the case
that what that
that that they couldn't know that
because miami if you could put it up
there gary all the uh picks in that
peter king proposal for miami yup uh
yeah you know to uh
chris wilkins tour
and then number three overall
after that
after that i just fall asleep
because that's the gist of it
because you know about 2022 and 2023 we
got d'shaw watson we'll be all right we
got the shot watson with help
we got health and productivity which the
texans did a limited passing game
yeah yeah
no i'm not going to get the best bets
22. 23 picks won't be that great
i think your best bets are probably
miami and san francisco
uh everybody else is kind of like you
know
whether it's carolina denver there are a
lot of other teams in the mix but
i it's just
it it just it's it's incredible
that they
would sit here and try to prove a point
when they have an opportunity to reboot
their franchise
you know i i'm sorry i'm just
to to have somebody to have somebody
that clearly does not want to be there
like how does that serve you go ahead
i'm sorry you bout to say something well
i was going to ask you a quick question
um
so i saw you pointing to your head when
i was talking about the j.j watt hey
where jj j.j watko's maybe
deshawn follows so are do you still feel
like jj's going to miami
it's possible
it might not be that nice and neat i'm
just saying that there is a there is a
relationship there that was forged
through fire
shall we say
um
and but if the texans but if the texans
make it difficult
and won't release desean obviously jj's
got to do what's best for jj i think
ideally jj would love to see where
desean watson goes and if it's some
place like if it is
if it is miami
then jj is like oh okay cool let's make
this happen let's make it happen captain
because miami ain't exactly cash cash or
cap strapped either
um again i could see the tech i
understand the texas reluctance for the
same reason we're talking about people
giving up the farm to get him i get them
not wanting to start over at that
position but like this ship has sailed
man this ship is safe i'm gonna say it's
not working
situation
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports